- Hello everyone, welcome.
Thanks so much for joining us.
It's great to see everyone here.
Hope re:Invent is going
really well for all of you.
The silent session format
is a little bit interesting
but we're not able to take
questions from the audience
but we will be around at the end.
So, definitely stick around and we'll have
a great discussion here today.
I'm Andrew Keating with LogicMonitor.
I lead product marketing there.
I'm joined by two incredible panelists
and my goal is to actually talk
as little as possible and
get these guys to be talking
because they and their organizations
are really leaders in
this AI era that we're in.
And so, we've got some questions
and some great conversation
teed up for you all
but really our goal here is
to really unpack Agentic AIOps
and discuss you know,
how LogicMonitor partners
with organizations like
Worldwide Technology
and NTT Data and really hear
from leaders in this space
who are you know, paving the way
for this kind of AI era
that we're in today.
So, I'm joined by Abhi
Lakhani from NTT Data.
He's the VP of Go-To-Market
for Cloud and Security in Americas
and Mike Cervasio who's
the global practice manager
for AIOps at Worldwide Technology.
So, we are gonna talk a little bit
about some road map items
on the LogicMonitor side.
If that comes up, you know
the usual disclaimers apply.
I think everybody's familiar with,
you know, forward looking
statements and all that.
So, our agenda today,
I'm gonna talk again,
as briefly as possible
to give you a little bit of
an orientation on LogicMonitor
and our point of view
around Agentic AIOps.
We're gonna talk about Agentic AI
and it's possibilities and observability
and then, you know,
we're gonna spend most of the time
with the discussion with these leaders
and talking about kind of,
how they see the future unfolding,
the path to autonomous IT
that really every
organization is on these days.
We will have, like I said,
plenty of time for questions at the end
so feel free to grab us
as the session wraps up.
We'll also have the opportunity
to continue the conversation
at the LogicMonitor booth at
the Worldwide Technology booth.
So, plenty of opportunity
for you all to get engaged.
Again, I'm Andrew, I lead
product marketing at LogicMonitor
joined by Abhi and Mike.
So, about LogicMonitor, in case
you're not familiar with us,
we've been around since 2007.
We're fully SAS Native
platform hosted on AWS.
We have over 100,000 software
users on our platform.
We're monitoring over
5 million devices a day
and collecting around
1.5 trillion metrics.
We have a bit over 1,000
employees globally.
We're placed in the Gardner
Magic quadrant as a challenger.
We've received a number of
customer awards and accolades.
We're really positioning ourselves
as a customer friendly option
for AI first observability.
We had some exciting news yesterday
and I encourage you all to look up
the announcement and the press release.
We have acquired Catchpoint
and Catchpoint is a leader in
digital experience monitoring,
internet performance monitoring.
They have over 3,000
points of presence globally
to monitor internet performance
and so bringing them
together with LogicMonitor,
and our strengths in
infrastructure monitoring
and observability, across
hybrid environments
together with Catchpoint's
strengths in IPM and DEM
really gives us the most comprehensive
observability platform to show
the full experience from user to code.
So, we announced this yesterday
but we do have Catchpoint
team members at our booth
so they're able to give
a demo of their platform.
It's really day one for us.
Actually day two but everyday is day one
in the Amazon frame of reference.
So, we're super excited to
bring the platform together
to create this comprehensive
observability platform.
The comprehensive data set
will be incredible for AIOps
and Agentic AI and we're
gonna talk more about that
throughout the course
of the session today.
- Can I just add one thing?
- Please, yeah.
- So, this is important with
all the internet outages
we've seen recently.
Unfortunately a three letter
acronym today that we hear,
Asure, Cloudflare, these are
gonna continue to happen.
Mostly due to changes and other things
but you need something to monitor,
give you the health status
of things you rely on
but don't necessarily own to understand
where the fault domain is.
- Yeah, it's a great point, Mike
and one thing about Catchpoint
for those of you who follow the space.
I mean, they've been
monitoring internet performance
for quite some time.
They actually had about 15 minutes,
they detected the most recent AWS outage,
a month or so ago, they
detected it 15 minutes prior
to anything being reported from AWS
because they have their own global network
that sits outside the hyperscalers
and that's really crucial when
we're doing so much of everything on AWS
and actually other hyperscalers as well.
- Sure.
- But, to be able to sort of understand
internet performance when
so much is in the cloud
is really critical.
So, you know a few trends that we see
and then we'll get to the questions
and discussion some more.
Observability and GenAI
and Agentic AI are really converging.
This is giving IT teams
not only the visibility
that observability
provides but the contacts,
the automated intelligence
and it's really crucial
to bring together that telemetry data,
the contextual knowledge in the ITSM,
in the knowledge base, and
also now bring in things
like internet performance data,
digital experience synthetics.
Bringing all that together provides us
really rich data set for AI
and with the rise of
Agentic AI for IT Ops,
you know, IT Ops is really
one of the best use cases
for letting loose AI agents, right?
And having an agent that performs
a lot of the functions that, you know,
in the past a human
might have to go and do
and you can orchestrate
agents to do things
like check the database performance,
check the network performance,
look at what's going on in the ITSM.
And so, there's really
this rise of Agentic AI
for IT Ops.
And this also leads to the shift
from just being concerned about visibility
and understanding, like what
is going on in the environment
to actually being able to take action
and ideally to be proactive
and to prevent incidents
before, before they would even happen
or impact end users or the business.
We see a few kind of value drivers
for Agentic AIOps
and these are pretty classic,
you know, aligning to the business.
First and foremost, improving
operational efficiency.
So, there's a world in which, you know,
you can't throw enough
human IT operations,
people at the problem.
You have to actually incorporate
and orchestrate AI agents
alongside humans in IT
Ops in order to achieve
efficiency gains.
It's also about kind of
reducing costs, right?
And for some organizations
that may mean shifting roles.
That may mean taking you know, fewer L1s
and we're gonna talk a
little bit more about that.
I'd love to hear you guys's
perspectives on that.
Yeah, boosting the productivity of the L1s
and others in IT operations
and ultimately ensuring that
the business is performing
and really you know, up time, MTTR,
keeping services running.
That's all in service
of our business goals
whatever industry, whatever
organization you're in.
It's really about turning IT efficiency
into measurable business growth.
So, that's enough talking from me.
I wanna turn to you guys
and first and foremost,
I mean LogicMonitor
has strong partnerships with
both your organizations,
with many other organizations.
I could talk about what we're doing
but I would rather hear
from, from both of you
around how we're working together
and so Mike, maybe we'll start with you
and then Abhi, would love to hear kind of
your perspective as well.
- Yeah absolutely, I mean, number one,
LogicMonitor with the
introduction of Edwin AI
has really set themself apart and now
the addition of Catchpoint
is getting stronger.
So, your number one ilick
for industry leaders,
thought leaders, but what
helps build the partnership
is the relationships.
Nothing to do with technology
and your partner program
and how you work together
to solve customer needs and requirements.
And then also, for me personally,
leveraging LogicMonitor and Edwin AI
in our advanced technology center
and our AI proving ground
where we have customers
testing out their AI use cases
before they you know, de-risk
an accelerated innovation.
So, LogicMonitor is one of our tier one
Go-To-Market partners that do that.
And you know, knowing people
like Andrew is you know,
that was the deal that sold it.
- Yeah, so for us, look we are
making a name for ourselves
as one of the only full stack
transformation companies
in the world and what that means is
anytime we are sitting down with customers
and talking full stack transformation,
full stack observability is table stakes.
So what, and we've seen a lot
of success with LogicMonitor
at, in a lot of industries
whether it's product,
manufacturing, now
starting to get into sled
where we're seeing a lot of the features
that the LogicMonitor stack has.
Enable when you couple
that with our MSD model
and our breadth across
the different types of
infrastructure cloud environment,
we're building some very,
co-creating some very
compelling solutions which
are driving real time value
for our customers.
I think that's, that's a
great partnership model
that we're looking to
continue to expand on
and take it across all sectors.
- Great, yeah, and just
to underscore the point.
I mean, you guys and your organizations
reflect different realms
of the partner ecosystem
and so there is the kind
of service offerings
that you're delivering for your customers,
the ability to test in
WWT's test environment
and then the practices and services
that both of your organizations
offer your customers.
So, it's really multifaceted partnership
with both organizations.
And then, we'll talk about
the AWS angle as well
because we're all
partnering with AWS also.
Great, and you know, I think
partnership is really key
and the industry has been talking about
monitoring to observability
and this journey
from reactive to proactive
for quite some time.
Like, that's not a new story,
but I think what has been changing
and what's been evolving,
you know AIOps has been
around for about a decade
as a concept and it
started with, you know,
machine learning.
It started with, you know,
deterministic kind of models
and having to kind of train the system
to have it learn a lot and now you know,
it's evolved into this Agentic state
which is very exciting.
We see this as a really
significant tipping point
for the industry and it's
something that is happening
because of partnerships like you know,
LogicMonitor with NTT,
with Worldwide Technology,
with the other partners that we have.
This is really the
thing that is propelling
the industry forward that
ultimately benefits you
and your organizations
as you're thinking about
what autonomous IT is gonna
look like in your organizations.
You've got you know,
a technology provider like LogicMonitor.
We're spending our days
thinking about that
and then we've got partner
organizations like this
that are, that are laser
focused on it as well.
- Yeah, and I love the term,
it's no longer optional, it's mandatory.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- Also observability and
autonomous IT Operations,
it's table, no it's not table stakes
but it's a differentiator.
Set yourself apart from excelling.
- Yeah, that's right
and I think, you know,
if we'd had this conversation a year ago
we might have had a different time horizon
but the urgency, the sense of
how fast things are changing
really doesn't make it
optional these days.
We've talked a little bit
about how we work together.
I'd love to double click
on this a little bit more
to talk about what the
value is for customers
and clients and Abhi, maybe
to start with you around that.
You know, NTT and LogicMonitor have been
working together for several years.
What do you see as the ways
that we're working together to drive value
for your clients and for your customers?
- Yeah, I think there's a
few aspects to it, right?
I think right off the bat,
the way we deliver manage services
has fundamentally
changed with partnerships
like we have at LogicMonitor, right?
I was having a conversation
with a customer
a couple days ago and,
they didn't wanna talk the traditional
L1 through L3 support model.
They were, they were pushing us on
why we even need an L1.
Like, why can't I have agents deployed
who can proactively track
events, correlate them,
bring in closed loop
automation for resolution,
do real time RCA?
Those are questions that you know,
up until six months ago were not part of
our core solutioning platforms.
They were, they were nice to have.
Now, we are forced to
think along those lines
because of the recent
successes we have seen
when you, when LogicMonitor
and NTT have gone to customers
and put these kind of
FSO solutions out there.
So, I think right off the bat
the way we are going
to market has changed.
The second thing I wanna
highlight is the flexibility
in how we are approaching customers.
Traditionally as a Mana services,
you're doing fixed cost,
fixed bed type of solutions
which are driven by SLAs.
Now, we have outcome based solutions
or outcome based models,
Go-To-Market models
that we can put in front of customers.
We have, other service options,
whether it's just consuming
an observability stack.
We have flexibility in
control of the infrastructure
and observability sweeps for customers.
I'll give you a very quick example
and then I'd love to hear
what Mike has to say.
We are working with a company
that's building a gigafactory
outside of Memphis,
Tennessee and they wanted to
have us come in and stand up
their entire infrastructure
including their knock and sock.
For the sock, they wanted us to deploy it
and they would manage it.
For the knock, they wanted us to build,
run, transform continuously.
Partners like LogicMonitor,
we have that flexibility where we could,
even within that space, give
them two very different models
and that's what customers are looking for.
They're looking for flexibility
in how they consume services.
From MSPs they're looking at,
they're very cost conscious
so that's something that I'm seeing
as a great add on with the
partnership with you guys.
- Yeah, and that's a fantastic example.
And I suspect, I mean, given,
NTT is very familiar with scale.
I mean, you guys have been
operating at global scale.
Gigafactories,
mega-gigafactories, scale is not,
you know, not a new thing for NTT
but I imagine that there's pressures
around speed of deployment.
So, you know, I won't put you on the spot
to mention how fast they
wanted that all deployed
but I suspect that the speed element
comes into play as well.
- It does and to be very honest
it makes us uncomfortable.
It does, because we are that giant
who's learning to run fast now.
- Yeah.
- And we need partners who
bring in those capabilities
off the bat instead of us investing time
in building said capabilities.
- Yeah.
- That's why these partnerships
become invaluable for us
because you know, you guys are helping us
get to that speed that
traditionally was foreign to us.
- Yep, and combining the speed and scale
is it's own challenge.
Well, Mike, from the reseller perspective
and that partner perspective,
you mentioned a little bit
about the test bed environment
and allowing kind of customers to come in
and actually test the
technology before deploying it
but what are some of the other ways?
I mean, I'd love to have
you talk more about that
and also, you know, other
ways that Worldwide Tech
and LogicMonitor are partnering together.
- Yeah, sure, good stuff, thank you.
Yeah, so for us, we're
getting a lot of demand
for tactical tool
replacements, that's fine,
but what I like even better
is more of a top down strategic approach.
Like, how do we build our
next generation Knock,
our next generation Sock,
our next generation
enterprise command center,
or as my alma mater calls
it now, mission control,
and how do we take back
if we've over-rotated to multiple MSPs,
how do we measure using SLOs
and change management risk
and leveraging AI,
how do we have that Agentic L1 response?
Where you know, when
it may not necessarily
be replacing headcount but at reducing
and freeing up those resources
to work on more strategic
transformational things.
I think that's Edwin AI
can do and we've seen it
and it's real.
The Agentic L1 response, it's not a myth
and like, for NTT, it can help
streamline your operations
and add more value, added services for us.
You know, it's showing a proof
of a multi OAM environment
which every customer's in.
How do you integrate that and leverage
event driven automation and now
the next generation of that
autonomous IT Op automation?
And getting to those insights
through the tsunami of noise alerts events
and get to a correlation.
And we have a reference
architecture methodology that we like.
When we go in, you probably
don't wanna hear this
but when we go into a customer
we wanna maximize and leverage
what they've already invested.
Um, and we'll uncover blind
spots and redundancies
but we've got opinions based on what
we've kicked the tires on everyday in
our advanced technology center
and we'll give our opinion
on not just LogicMonitor
and it's capabilities but
the Edwin AI capability
and how that's changing the game.
And now with Catchpoint...
- Yeah.
- That'll be a great new path for us.
- Yeah, I was just thinking
and we don't have to commit to it here
but I think getting Catchpoint
into the mix as well
is gonna be, is gonna make it
even more, more compelling.
- Yeah, 'cause to me where
the rubber meets the road
is that user experience.
- Yeah.
- Digital user experience.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
Digital user experience.
That's your business health.
- Yeah.
- Like for American
Express when I was there,
it was measuring the card member journeys.
Mapping that, instrumenting
that from stem to stern
across multiple hosting domains,
mainframe, across the gambit.
That's the true health, not hey,
my network's up, my applications are up
but my customers are still having issues.
- Yeah, and I think with
this and synthetics...
- Yes.
- Being able to run those tests as well.
So, you know, we've been talking,
we just jumped right in and
we started talking about
Agentic AIOps, Mike,
you've mentioned you know,
Edwin AI is our Agentic AIOps product.
AIOps as a concept has been,
is a decade or so old.
The concept, everybody's talking about AI
so I think like, to take a step back maybe
you know, what do you guys see as
making Agentic AIOps so different
from kind of just traditional AI
or machine learning models
or even just you know, kind of good old
if this happens then
do some action, right?
Would love to get your
perspectives on this
and Mike, maybe we'll start with you.
What do you see is fundamentally different
with Agentic AIOps?
- Um, it's the ability
to take multiple actions.
So, in, you know, machine
learning's been around forever.
Pattern matching, event correlation,
that's been around for a while
but this autonomous way to,
you know, still using
LLMs with RAG is the brain
but now using Agentic AI to you know,
make recommendations, in
seconds analyze what changed,
you know, checking the change
of management database,
knowledge articles, product manuals,
even conversational unstructured
data in your slack channels
and bringing that to the forefront of that
strategic resource, the SRE person
that would normally take
10s of minutes if not hours
and do that in seconds.
You know, everyone has dashboards
but just probably each
organizational unit has it.
Their own persona based dashboard.
How do you quickly
interpret those in seconds?
That's Agentic AI.
- Yeah, that's great
and Abhi would love your perspectives.
We talked about kind of speed and scale
and what are you seeing and
what is your team seeing
around the differences with Agentic AIOps?
- Yes, I think for us
it's two fold, right?
One is the core design principle behind
any Agentic AI ecosystem is the modularity
and the unit based elementary
design principles, right?
So, that's where I think that Agentic AI
differentiates itself from traditional AI
because when you have
autonomous independent agent
working in a closed loop
collaborative AI system,
you're making decisions at speed.
You're learning from
continuous speed back loops
and you're continuously
improving not just the service
that said agents are providing
but the infrastructure
and the environment health
that continues to improve
because of the actions
these agents take, right?
So, that flexibility and
those marginal benefits,
when you start scaling those,
that's where real value is driven.
Right, I think that's one
thing that's big for us.
The second thing is
you're seeing a lot of,
you know we talk a lot about speed
but it's the, it's the
intelligence combined
with that speed which is making,
which is driving these
values for customers.
Some of my customers are
not looking at SLAs anymore.
They are looking at
environment improvement.
They're asking us to
track patterns and trends
in their infrastructure
usage and correlate those
with some of their business events.
Some business trigger events.
Agentic AI is the answer,
or is the path to measuring
those kind of outcomes.
- That's really great and I think that's,
I mean, we're only beginning that.
So, it's like, if we project forward
it's gonna be kind of mind boggling.
You know, that initial
shift that you described
from an SLA into actually
being more proactive
and to improving the environment.
I mean, imagine what we'll be saying
in a year or two from now when more
and more of your customers
have implemented that.
- Yep, absolutely.
- And so Abhi, let's stick with you
and talk, you've mentioned
a little bit already
around the shifts in the MSP model.
I was especially interested
in what you shared about
your clients actually asking for you know,
AI agents in place of L1s potentially.
Are your clients kind of
thinking through that?
But, I'd love you to say
more about the changes
that you're seeing in the MSP model
as a result of AIOps and Agentic AI.
- Look, like I said, right,
I mean, there's the
traditional levels where,
you know, your Agentic AIOps is helping us
reduce the cost.
Right?
And that's, in today's
market in the MSP space,
you know that's becoming a core function
of what we take to our customers, right?
Most customers ask for
40, 45, 50% productivity
over a three year term.
You don't do that through
the traditional levels
of sourcing and parameter
adjustments, right?
You've got to find ways
to reduce the environment
that you're serving in order to get there.
So, AIOps gets you that, right?
The second thing is,
some of the predictive
and proactive monitoring
helps you prevent incidents
before they become incidents, right?
And that's something that most customers
have come to expect from us, right?
So, those are a couple of things
and then the third thing is,
you know with real time RCAs,
with close loop automation
around elimination at source
for some of the root causes,
that's helping you reduce the environment
that you are serving which in turn
is driving value, not
just for our customers
but for us internally as well.
And as an MSP there's only
a limited set of delivery headcount
that any organization can maintain
while being cost effective, right.
So, we have got to make sure our resources
are secundered to projects
while keeping in mind
that we have a large
customer base to serve.
And that's where the technology of AIOps
is coming and helping us.
- Yeah, that's great and Mike,
I wonder, you're working
with MSPs and end clients.
Like, what's your take on this?
Are you hearing kind of similar things?
- Yeah, it's definitely
like for the Telco's,
where the network is their business
and also for financial services obviously,
we're seeing a push to you know,
help them create and
Agentic network assistant.
Kind of that would be the
overall brains, the orchestrator
but then plugging into the Agentic AI loop
where you've got something like Edwin AI
that it's gonna pull
and then also your agent
can talk to the Dynatrace,
Davis AI agent talk to the
new Datadog bits AI agent
and bring that in to contact.
'Cause if you need that
application deep visibility
to find out what's going on,
is it something in your code?
And then obviously with Catchpoint
being able to determine,
is it something out in the internet
that's outside your firewalls?
So, yeah we're definitely seeing
the MSPs, the Telcos, the GSPs
as leading the way to help them get to,
get ahead of the curve
and stop being blamed.
That meantime innocence,
being able to be proactive
if not very prescriptive and predictive
for service disruptions.
And get ahead of that
instead of that react,
and some of it's people
process skills culture,
but it's also technology
and it's really starting,
you know, looking at that whole gambit
and it's, you know observability in AIOps
is a team sport.
It needs to be end to end.
- Yeah, I think that's right
and I also see it as you know,
you mentioned some of the agent to agent
and sort of MCP type infrastructure.
That is definitely an
emerging area that we're
investing in and you're gonna see
a lot more from us in that sense
in terms of being able to enable Edwin
to talk to other agents,
whether it's ServiceNow or you know,
some other set of agents
and then I think, you know,
picking up on what you said as well,
I also see a convergence of the needs
that end customers have as
well as the MSP dynamics.
And so, these are worlds that
in a sense are converging
and it's similar sets of concerns.
And even if you're at an IT organization
at an enterprise you know,
you can learn some things
from the way MSPs are operating.
You may be working with MSPs
and so all of these elements kind of
are coming together and converging.
And you know, of course
we're here at re:Invent.
We're all in the AWS
partner ecosystem as well.
We'll talk about AWS
marketplace in a few minutes.
LogicMonitor as a platform
uses AWS as our infrastructure.
Would love to hear more
about how your organizations
are working with AWS and how AWS services
come into the mix with
everything we're speaking about.
And maybe Abhi, we'll start with you
around what you can
share about AWS services,
whether that's AI
applications or more broadly
how you all partner
with and work with AWS.
- Yeah, this is a very,
very exciting space for us.
We are, we have been traditionally known
to be a large infrastructure
company, right?
So, when we are talking to customers
about their AI initiatives,
the first thing that comes to mind is,
how can a partner like
NTT build a scalable,
nimble AI foundation?
And we call it the horsepower, right?
But, and we bring in some of those combued
and storage elements to it
with technology such as Bedrock, right?
That helps you design those,
those flexible but at the same time
cost effective foundations that customers
no longer have to invest
capital in, right?
So, that's a huge area where
we're partnering with Amazon
around Bedrock and then
building these foundations.
Then you start getting
into what we call as
your curated AI orchestration lair.
That way where you're building
and managing an environment
where a customer, we're
giving them all the plugins,
they need to connect
all their data sources
whether it's their MRPs
and their ERP systems,
their metadata systems, their real,
their factory floor scale systems.
So, all that data ingestion
comes to customers as a service
instead of them again
investing and building these.
And then you start thinking
about things like SageMaker.
That's a great tool set
within the Amazon ecosystem
that helps us build
that kind of capability.
And then you start getting
into the agent to agent
collaboration that Mike
was talking about, right?
They look at things like Amazon queue,
they, that is accelerating,
all of this is technology
everybody's experimenting with.
People are finding challenges around
whether it's domain specific.
Challenges whether it's
security compliance challenges
but that, these are the kind of things
that are giving us headstart in that
from the Amazon ecosystem
that is giving us
the acceleration that
customers are looking for.
- Yeah, that's great.
Mike, what about you?
How's Worldwide Technology
working with AWS services
in the AI space?
- Yeah sure, so those
products that were mentioned,
definitely extending those capabilities
to the operational models
that the LogicMonitor
and Edwin AI could bring.
It's like that Agentic loop
that I was talking about
but also, just from working
with Amazon on migrations.
From on-prem to AWS,
being able to give that
performance baseline
before, during, and after the migration.
'Cause a lot of folks either refactor
or lift and throw over the fence.
There are applications
that may not be optimal
for Cloud Native.
You need to be able to
quickly determine that
with a tool like LogicMonitor.
Cloud Watch and some of the newer tools
that we just mentioned.
You need to see that full visibility.
You need to see behind the curtain as well
whereas you know,
companies like Catchpoint,
ThousandEyes, tell you up to a point,
up to the front door
of AWS what's going on.
You need to see behind the scenes.
What's really going on in your S3 buckets
and a lot of these tools for Marketplace
that a lot of companies are using
for data link analysis
and that correlation.
- Yeah, I think that's right
and one of the things we're looking at
from the LogicMonitor perspective
is the observability and monitoring
of the AI workloads themselves.
So I mean, we have
multiple dimensions here
to think through, so we have observability
over all those AWS AI services
as well as a number of others
in terms of cloud monitoring.
I think cost comes into play as well.
Mike, ensuring that you're optimizing
for resource allocation and cost
certainly comes into a factor there.
So, we on the LogicMonitor side of things
are thinking about this both
as a consumer of AWS services ourselves,
facilitating clients and their migrations
and their use of AWS services
with you know, partners like these.
And then, also ensuring
that IT Operations teams
that are running these
services day in and day out
have full visibility
into what's happening.
At the cloud layer and then now
with the addition of Catchpoint,
being able to see that
at the internet layer,
the user layer as well.
- Yeah, it's kind of the other
side of the same coin, right?
You need AI for observability.
You also need observability in AI
or your AI ecosystems,
whether it's in the cloud
or on-prem, like I know
AWS announced factories.
Kind of like almost like
an AI pod in your on-prem.
That should be bundled with the
business health capabilities
that LogicMonitor and Edwin AI bring
to manage and understand the work flows.
Are the LOMs operating?
Are they pulling accurate data?
Have the sources changed?
Not just GPU monitoring.
You know, but the work
flows, the LOMs, the agents.
Giving you, you know, your
investment is paying off
as you intended.
- So, we've talked a
little about this already
but coming back to you know,
what we're using and I'm gonna
broaden the question a little bit.
We're talking about MSPs but I think it's
actually more broadly like enterprises
as well as MSPs kind of using AI agents
to solve real problems
in their organizations
and in their operations
and so Mike, maybe you
could say a little bit more
about what you're seeing there.
You mentioned financial services.
You mentioned a few industries
but say more about how AI agents
are kind of working in production today
to solve real problems for organizations.
- Yeah, it's kinda that moving,
I'm seeing companies
moving from having people
that are martyrs to working smarter.
That rhymes on purpose.
Martyr to smarter.
But anyway...
- You should be in marketing.
- Anyway, there's a lot of tasset tribal,
my wife says tribal
knowledge is not PC correct
but tasset knowledge.
These engineers that have CCIEs
and been doing it for decades
and just have that intrinsic knowledge.
How do we capture that?
In not just knowledge based articles
but what do they typically do?
What are the three or
four steps these SMEEs do
to understand the fault domain?
You know, get the isolation
then get to the root cause.
Like I said, look at your
last six months of incidents.
Did this happen before?
What was the blast radius?
What was the fix?
Do that with AI, Agentic AI in seconds
versus the 10s and 10s of
minutes, hours it may take
for someone to do that manually
and not to replace those SMEEs.
It's more of a digital colleague, right?
You still need a human in the loop.
It's just getting them to work smarter
versus you know being on
those long bridge call,
warrior calls.
- Yeah, I think you know,
I think every organization's
gonna think through this
like what is replacement,
what is augmentation
and finding that right mix?
Because even the best
subject matter expert
in their specific domain doesn't
have the domain knowledge
of all the other domains, right?
- [Mike] Right.
- So, the database guy is
calling the network guy
and the network guy is
calling the infrastructure guy
or what not, so putting
AI agents in to the mix
is gonna augment even the
best subject matter expert
in their domain by giving them access
to other domain knowledge.
Abhi, you've talked a
bit about the services
that NTT is delivering and your approach
to leveraging AI agents.
Would love to hear more around
how you're using AI
agents to solve problems
for your clients.
- Yes, so for us,
one of the things that differentiates us
from the rest of the
MSPs that we compete with
is we have a very tool and
platform driven approach
to MSP solutions.
So, we invest heavily in
enhancing our platform capability
and bringing all these AI agents.
We do a lot of internal IT.
The IT that we serve
within our organization
across the globe, we use AI...
- Eat your own caviar.
- We do, we absolutely do.
- It's not dog food, it's caviar, right?
- Thank you so much.
That's a good choice of words.
So, we use a lot of,
we use a lot of Agentic AI
and LogicMonitor solutions
to do event correlation
that will noise suppression.
Then analysis, anomaly
detection, incident triage,
we are actually using a lot of that
in our internal IT Ops, right?
I'll give another example.
We use, we are starting to
adopt a lot of Agentic AI
or rather agents for some of
our Go-To-Market functions.
Right?
In some of our operational
and financial functions.
So, there is, this goes beyond serving
just our customers and our
customers love to hear that story
because they're looking for partners
who are actually, like you said,
eating their own caviar.
We are showing them examples of how we,
and again, just a quick
sidebar about NTT, right?
We have been a collection of companies.
We have been, over the
years built capability
by acquiring a lot of niche companies
and integration has been a
continuous challenge for us.
And when we go to customers and tell them,
we understand, for example,
we open the door of
private equity companies
and we tell them, we know what it is
to integrate Opcos together.
We know how to standardize operations
and infrastructures together.
Those are the kind of stories
that gel with our customers
because of some of this caviar
that we are eating
ourselves and showing them
the results of.
- Yeah, same with Worldwide.
We like to eat our own caviar as well.
You know, we've built our
own Agentic network assistant
because someone new coming
into a company our size
it's hard to find things.
It's all over the place
and also since we do a lot of RFPs,
an RFP AI assistant.
Let's try to simplify things
and show that we use it.
And also our own internal
IT operations team
uses LogicMonitor for the operations
of the warehouses, factories,
and the advanced technology center.
So, I think that says a lot.
If we're using LogicMonitor
for our own internal IT
there's something there.
- Yeah, well we at
LogicMonitor use LogicMonitor
on LogicMonitor, we actually...
- No way.
- Yeah, who'd have thought, right?
But we're very much in that,
drink our own champagne,
eat our own caviar
kind of club as well and in fact
at our annual customer conference
that was our sort of mainstage demo.
Rather than having marketing folks like me
come up with some fictitious scenario
we actually did a demo of
our own use of LogicMonitor
across our infrastructure and our AWS
and other kind of global infrastructure
to deliver our own platform.
And some of the first integration
points with Catchpoint
and LogicMonitor, it's, you
know, the Catchpoint team
using LogicMonitor to
understand their infrastructure
and LogicMonitor using Catchpoint.
So, that's one of the first things
as we were starting the
integration discussions
it was getting those teams together
and you know, you can even,
well, we'll talk about going
to our booth in a minute
and giving the commercial for that
but you can even see some of that
at our booth here at re:Invent.
You know, so your
organizations are all in.
It sounds like your clients
are sort of asking you
like, how do we go quickly?
How do we do this now?
But, you know, what should organizations
be thinking about in terms
of their readiness for AIOps
and Agentic AI?
Because there's a lot of buzzwords.
There's a lot of
marketing speak out there.
There's a lot of urgency to go quickly
and to move quickly.
What should organizations
be thinking about?
And Mike, maybe we'll
start with you on that.
- Yeah sure, we do a
lot of AIOps workshops
and we try to do, you know a baseline of
where they're currently at.
Are they still in that crawl stage?
Still doing reactive
monitoring, firefighting?
Are they starting to be a
little bit more proactive?
To you know prescriptive, to predictive?
And a lot of companies need to
first unify the observability
'cause there's a lot of siloed fiefdoms.
All this spare data.
All these huge haystacks of data
and you need to help them
to find the right needle
at the right time and that's
what AIOps can do for them.
It's not a tool.
It's a discipline of
people, process, culture,
and yes, the right technology.
So, a lot of the things
we're working on is that,
the next operating model,
what should our operating model look like
to take advantage of things
like AIOps and Agentic AI?
And it's, you know
organizational structure wise
it's skill wise, and it's
also the right technology.
And having that unified
integrated end to end view
of a healthier business.
- Yeah, that's great.
Abhi, what's your perspective on this?
You've already been working with
a number of clients around this.
What should they be thinking about?
- Yeah, and look, it's very easy
to get preachy on this topic, right?
Because everybody has
an opinion on how AIOps
should be adopted.
You know, I'll give you live examples
of what we are seeing with
some of our customers, right?
I think the number one
challenge we are seeing is
that change in mindset and culture, right?
That need to continue to hug a system
and not rely on an autonomous agent.
That need to fundamentally,
like Mike said, right,
rethink your operating model.
- Yeah.
- Right?
It's, it's a very easy topic to talk on.
It's incredibly difficult to execute.
Some of, in fact, some of the places
where we are starting
to see success in AIOps
even with LogicMonitor and well talk about
this healthcare IT company.
The intent was there from day one
and yet it has taken us 12 months
to start building the true FSO capability.
And a lot of it had to do with adoption
and that change in mindset.
Yeah, so that's a huge example.
The second thing that,
and again this is not,
this is something we are
learning from customers.
Customers are getting
very good at setting small
measurable goals.
You know, up until six months ago
we used to go to customers saying,
where do you see yourself in this journey
five years from now?
Now it's where are you seeing yourself
six months from now?
And just by, just by bringing those goals
into bit sized consumable,
actionable units
people are starting to see some benefits
and those successes are driving the next
vehicle of initiatives along the AIOps.
So, those are the two things
we are seeing in the market
with some of our customers.
- Yeah, that's great.
I would just add into this,
I mean, one of the things we've seen
from the LogicMonitor perspective
is the importance of just getting going.
Just starting and doing something.
So our cells internally,
we have enterprise chat GPT
and we've actually been
recognized by Open AI
as having very high adoption.
So, we have something like 95% or more
of our company that are using chat,
our enterprise chat GPT on a weekly basis
and so that happened
because we got access to it
and we were encouraged
to simply start using it.
It's a little bit of a different dynamic
when we're talking about IT Operations
but what we see and what
we encourage clients to do
is to start a POV, right?
Work with you all in the
test bed type environment
just to try something and to get going
and some of our clients that
have started on that POV
have literally within an hour
started to see, you know,
Edwin making suggestions,
reducing noise, and then it
starts this flywheel going.
So, I think the biggest thing,
I mean, the culture challenges,
the culture shifts are real.
We're all only human
but I think the biggest thing I would say
is to just try and to just get going
and wherever you are in this,
you know define a use
case, define something
that you wanna try and
just sort of make a start.
- One thing I'll add.
You know, like for
organizations like ourself,
whether it's LogicMonitor or the WWTs
or MSPs like us, right?
It's very important to
set the right expectation
with some of our customers.
And then we have been guilty
of this as well, right?
Where we have probably sometimes gone in
and oversold the AIOps story.
In reality, these, these
measurable outcomes
kind of help us level set
customer expectations on day one.
So, you're not going and setting a stage
with a customer where they're saying,
within six months you can eliminate
your entire L1 function.
That's not gonna happen.
- Right.
- Right?
That could be an intent
but there's a path to it
and the technology frankly
is evolving everyday
and trying to catch up with that vision.
- Yeah.
- So, those are some of the things
that are becoming very relevant
in client conversations
around AIOps.
- Yeah, I think definitely starting small
like starting with a showcase MVP.
Pick a one critical user journey
and one critical service and let's,
you know, instrument the heck out of it
and you know, bring in that,
the right people, the right skillset,
the right technology and
measure the pre and post
and that in itself could help maybe solve
the cultural divide and say,
this is real.
I wanna do this now for the
next set of applications
and services
- Yep.
Well, as we start to wind down here,
love to put on our kind of
prediction crystal ball.
It's always dangerous to do
because things are moving so quickly
but you know, autonomous IT
has been on the agenda as a topic.
It's been discussed for decades.
It's not a new concept itself
but our sense is is that
it's closer than ever
to realization and I'd
love to hear you guys,
if not predicting, then at least like,
what do you see coming, you know,
in the immediate term time horizon
in terms of autonomous IT systems
and so Abhi, love your thoughts on this
and then Mike, we'd love
to hear from you as well.
- I think we, all of us in this space
have learned a lesson from
the cloud rush, right?
Decade, 15 years ago where
everything was moved to cloud.
Lift and shift, became
the standard pattern.
Organizations started to
realize the diminishing value
of that approach and since then
the decision making for customers
has become very intelligent.
In the cloud parland,
we're no longer talking to
customers about move the cloud.
We're talking to customers about
move to the right execution venue for you.
That could be a hybrid STA,
it could be a completely
private airgapped estate.
That same principle is
what I expect to apply in AI adoption.
Like, customers would want to see value.
We talked about POVs, right?
There's a couple of areas
where we're not seeing the
benefits of that POV approach
because POVs are translated
as science experiments.
Yes, you can go deploy
an autonomous chat bot
and make it language aware.
Where is the real ROI
for that coming for me?
Right?
So, what I'm, what I expect to see is
there will be gradual adoption of the
services software model where you have
an entire end to end business process
being completely driven by agent
but the path to that is
going to have to be built
on some very small victory blocks.
Each with it's own measurable value
that can stand on it's own.
That's something we'll definitely see.
- Mike, what's your perspective on this?
- Well, I predicted you guys
would acquire Catchpoint.
- So, you've got a really,
you've got a really good crystal ball.
- But you know, definitely just to add on.
You know, it's that, AI's
not gonna replace everything.
People's jobs, you know,
it may change your jobs
but it's a collaboration.
It's like I said, a digital colleague
that's gonna work alongside you
with your supervision.
And you know, to me
the most practical use,
if you've got an AI budget
like everyone has had
in the last 18 months,
the most practical use cases, AIOps
or now autonomous ITs operations
and bringing that intelligence forward
and stop being reactive and start being,
firefighting and be fire prevention
and free up your resources.
And also, the thing I'm seeing change is
be a first class citizen.
Observability has a seat at the table.
Observability and AIOps by design.
Don't wait for something to,
you know, a transformation project
to build a new data
center or network refresh
and then say, oh shoot,
we're having performance issues, why?
It should be a first
class citizen by design.
- One thing if I may add,
just very quickly, right?
It's, the one area that I think
we're gonna see a very rapid adoption
of Agentic AI is, as we say in our world,
moving up the lairs.
Right, so traditionally for MSPs
come and show me my
infrastructure is healthy
and then we move on to your
integration and API lairs
and your data lairs and
your application lairs.
A lot of our customers
are moving through those,
those stairs very quickly.
So, I'll give you an example.
There's a customer we started working with
about 12 months ago.
It's a national insurance company.
We started our Agentic AI and
AIOps MSP journey with them
as just infrastructure management
and within 12 months they have worked
successfully with us to build an entire
end to end plain processing
as a service model.
Now, this was a company
who was ready to fail fast.
They were ready to make
some of those investments
but they didn't want to,
they didn't want to spend too much time
in driving the value just from
your infrastructure and IT lairs.
They wanted to very
quickly move up the ladder
and move into the business lairs.
So, that's the hope.
That for some of our customers
is we find enough customers
who are willing to make that leap.
Willing to fail and,
because that's where the future is.
The future of AIOps or Agentic AI
is not in as we call it,
the underground lair, right?
The true value is gonna
come in the business lairs.
- Yeah.
- That's the hope more than a prediction.
- Absolutely and connecting it
to the business outcomes
and the value is really key.
As we start to wrap up here
just sharing you a quick snapshot of the
three year, multi year vision
that we're orienting around
at LogicMonitor.
We've shown this to
several different audiences
over the past few months.
One was an audience at
our annual analyst council
so this is a closed door session
with about 20 of the leading
observability IT Ops analysts
in the space and their consensus was,
all right, looks good, go ahead and do it.
Then about a few weeks later
we showed it to our
executive advisory board
which is about 15 or so execs
spanning industries,
MSPs, financial services,
other industries, they
looked at this and they said,
can you go faster?
And you know, there may be a little bit of
selection bias in that
because they're obviously
a forward looking group
but what we're hearing across the board
and the pressure that's on our product
and engineering teams is to basically
deliver on this vision
to provide that value
to all of you and to partners
to provide to your clients
and your own customers.
We see it as starting
with Agentic automation
which is here now.
We have a partnership with IBM Ansible.
So, you have Edwin being
able to connect into Ansible
and trigger those run books.
We see this moving very quickly
into a multi agent
swarming type environment.
So, replicating you know,
what would happen with humans today,
where the database guy
talks to the network guys,
well that's gonna be multiple
agents swarming together
on a problem.
And very quickly we see
this going to zero touch
and truly to this self
healing type data center model
that has been talked about for some time.
And you know, it's probably
an overused analogy
of self driving cars
and autonomous driving
but you know, I do find it
a useful one to think with
because some of us have taken a Waymo
or used a full self driving kind of mode,
others have not and we've just used
some of the features of that
to enhance our driving experience.
And so, I think the autonomous IT future
is here today.
It's happening now and organizations
are going to adopt
different elements of it
to suit their business needs
and their business outcomes
and you know, it's great partners like NTT
and Worldwide technology that
are gonna make that happen.
And you know, there's a
lot of pressure I think
on all of us to deliver
this vision very quickly
for our respective clients.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Of course, have to give
a commercial announcement
for our, us on the AWS Marketplace.
LogicMonitor is there.
We also partner with AWS.
Edwin AI, our Agentic AIOps product
is available on the Agentic
Marketplace with AWS.
So, that's the kind of
commercial announcement.
Check us out on the Marketplace.
The other commercial announcement
as we start to wrap up here
is to come by our booth, 1467.
We have demos there.
We've got folks that are able to demo
and show you what the platform looks like.
Show you what Edwin AI
looks like in action.
You can try it yourselves.
We've also got some fun activations.
You can become, our booth
theme is Mission AI Possible.
So, you can become a certified AI,
AI agent yourself and we
encourage you all to do that.
But on a serious note,
we also have the Catchpoint team there.
So, you can actually see
Catchpoint in action.
You can see Edwin in action.
As we start to wrap up here,
any kind of final thoughts
from our panel here?
Parting words?
Abhi, we'll start with you.
- I think, it's very encouraging
what we're seeing in the market
with this partnership and our goal,
I think one thing where we're aligned is,
we're aligned on ambition.
We're aligned on the speed.
We're starting to align on the technology
and how what LogicMonitor
brings to the table
fits seamlessly into what some of
our core offerings around MSP space are.
We've got to be, we've got to be quick.
We've got to put pressure on each other.
We've gotta go and make
commitments to customers
that may not be completely
feasible on day one
but that's, I think that's
where growth comes from, right?
So, I'm personally very
excited with this partnership
and what we're taking
together to the market.
It's a very strong story
and I just hope for,
over the next 12 months
we can become, we can come back here
and make some announcements on what
we've been able to drive
as value for customers.
- That's great.
Mike, you've got the countdown clock.
You've got a minute and a half.
Parting words, parting
words of wisdom here, Mike.
- Don't be afraid to lean in.
Even if it's just a
consultation advisement.
We wanna give you our
perspective on the industry
and you know, just a little announcement,
by the end of this month
we're gonna have Edwin AI fully launched
in our advanced technology center.
- Yeah, it's great.
- So, you get to kick the tires
and have a launchable lab
and see how it integrates
with all the other OEMs
and that are in everyone's environment.
- And, we'll work on
Catchpoint next, right?
- Yes.
- I mean, that's where we go next.
But, no that's a great note
and I think one of the
things we've talked about
is there's multiple pathways in, right?
So, there's your test bed environment.
There's the POV route,
there's the traditional demo type route,
but like, the overall
message is to get going.
Work with partners,
talk with LogicMonitor,
you know no time like the present
to get started and to move quickly so...
- Absolutely.
- With that I think we will wrap up
and thank you so much, Abhi, Mike,
really appreciate your
perspectives on this world
that we're in.
Please do come by the LogicMonitor booth.
Worldwide Technology's
got a booth as well.
So, you can go to the WWT booth also.
We will be around afterwards
if folks wanna ask us
any individual questions
or come find us at the booths.
And again, thank you Abhi, thank you Mike,
really appreciate it.
- [Abhi] Thanks for having us.